so today's topic I got a video I want to
show preach you're so cute your
guillotine
jubilee again yes in for our daily dose
of dating games let's make sure that we
shout out Jubilee so we don't give us a
strike under childhood [ __ ] yeah
listen right now probably look like I'm
smaller than ever because I sprained my
ankle you are in your childhood
yeah we just need a backdrop with lasers
in the back if it was not for my ankle
that would walked out I'll do it for you
it's interesting I feel like whenever
they come up with these ideas they kind
of try to always reinvent themselves so
I feel like somebody was in the board
meeting like how could a girl date a guy
in a different way what if she was
staring at pictures of the guy when it
was illegal imagine he has that a guy
yeah we're gonna ask you to go for that
yeah she less might be cute I think I'd
like to sleep with you when you're legal
but no woman whatever a woman says oh
yeah wasn't gonna be um tell him to call
me when he's old creep the process of
growing to being who you are now is a
really important process to recognize I
think that my childhood made me who I am
today because of where I grew up to and
my hobbies and that gives you said
literally nothing my childhood made me
who I am today
boo boo everyone's childhood made them
who they are today I'm not gonna sweat
too much yeah you don't proceeded to
loon without commenting on that
cuz you know you sweat with your hey I
said no we're not commenting on that
[Music]
okay just looking at these guys I can
tell these guys got some childhood
issues and someone making fun of them
for how they looked as the baby's gonna
hurt they just look like they're waiting
for validation trike yeah where are you
from I'm originally from Washington no
way so my okay yeah the two like little
buck teeth in the front I wish he would
do this but with the genders reversed
you can as a double offender you can't
we mentioned this before a guy cannot be
like oh [ __ ] you look pretty nice when
you know you change I mean yeah I'm
happy person what is on your shirt it
says bungle boy oh boy oh boy
thank you was whether you go with a jean
company and Google boy was just there
treatment tomorrow for kids would you
say that you dressed yourself a lot as a
kid
I think my parents did do you feel like
that changed over time like my parents
still you're wearing some some sick
overalls and you're climbing a ladder
doesn't it look like Vince staples
oh no Vince Naples is the rapper you
know the rapper who trolls everybody he
does look like him but I don't know who
that is
I got artist vibes from you my family
used to give me a lot of blank paper and
I used to just make my own pictures are
you an artist at all I am yeah yeah she
got one of those smiles that just makes
you angry you know I mean you know those
girls who smile so big that you start to
want to smile a little bit but you don't
want to smile and I mean yeah you're a
horrible person like you don't smile
that are infectious you don't like that
no cuz it's you're forcing forcing it
yeah if if you smiling it makes you
smile you're not forcing she's using her
do you think our position of power to
influence there's a work like that
it's called charm so you hate it right
now yeah cuz it's not reflecting how I'm
feeling on the inside but she's breaking
out the happiness of me then good maybe
she's the one for you know maybe maybe I
want to live in my Evanescence
[Music]
oh yeah I love teaching you should
definitely teach me good date that's a
new move bro
sledding you know you don't go in the
first thing like hey girl could you
teach me something it's not how it works
it looks like it's working you're eating
some toast with some Jam oh yeah yeah
you see it's pretty messy which I love
because I think kids can be messy about
it I love both my parents cooking I
really want to be able to make the same
food they did to like that same level
you're so tiny in this photo I promise I
was bigger than I look I can squat squat
no I swear I'm you know you can't you
know you can't raise yourself in that
little big to me I was a kid that was
bigger
I was balking keep a bib on that says I
love my mommy I have a couple of shirts
that say I love my mommy back in the day
doesn't watching this feel illegal yes I
don't think two grown-ass men should be
watching people watching baby pictures
it's too much watch I agree let's play
well you look amazing Hannah you're so
cute I don't even think that I would
ever say this in my life but this feels
very problematic and also it's okay to
say some babies are ugly
yes some babies are ugly but he's not
only this is a cute little baby it's a
cute little baby listen if the FBI's
listening that's only his stance and not
mine
hey while this baby look like uncooked
cookie dough because it's normal like
it's not all babies that look cute and
you know yeah but this [ __ ] it looks
like he just went through ten rousers
Deontay Wilder Turner's death you know
we've been fighting for and still
fighting to this day to this day to this
day you know you're in the pool for an
hour and your fingers is a nine months
[ __ ] your face would look like
but this baby looks like it's been
through something listen I'm gonna have
babies eventually are you they're gonna
be ugly most babies are ugly let's be
fair with something all right
most baby babbling newborn babies or me
boys they can't see [ __ ] and they all
got that to me and that's a word for not
that's name really listen English people
you don't know that French word but if
you listen to it that person looks hot
that's me that's what you look like you
don't even have to understand what it is
alright you're so so little you have to
be like a couple weeks old or something
yeah this is a piece I like to call new
phone who dis new phone who dis what is
they like the meaning behind your name
shy on an ancient Persian was a name
that meant worthy or king like I mean
you're posing like a king in this photo
as a baby holy
I was likes coconut fell down you're
worthy of illumination this guy's
definitely gonna be done Mario first
that was literally the baby un that's an
ugly baby I actually have a date after
yes imagine having your ego hurt because
someone said when you were four months
old baby you were ugly okay so you gotta
be out here like look at this one's
sucking his thumb like he's still what
is that look he's
he's definitely got crazy eyes going but
let's carry on this picture of you you
have glasses and stuff my mom is like
hey if you wear these glasses you'll get
tunnel women so they did not work but
you know you know I think there was a
rumor going around because I also like
faked my vision to get glasses I'm like
wondering like oh is he thinking like
he's feeling himself what was your
favorite subject in elementary school I
loved history I don't even care about
the baby picture this is you reaching
took me back to a different time you
know okay probably like recess autumn
it's my favorite season me too yeah I
think there's like so much coziness to
it and all this smells like cinnamon so
you'd rather like spend time outside
than inside oh yeah yeah definitely I
mean I love hiking
oh great me too me too did you play
basketball I did play basketball for
about a year I wasn't that good I might
have been good as like a seventh grader
but I'm not that good now hey man the
last guy are the only ones who sounded
like they have confidence everyone else
sounds dweeby me I have a sound live
phone because she's not just basing this
off of life what she's looking she's
listening to what they're saying
of course yeah I know what you're
thinking what am I thinking
this kid has a dumb-looking face all
right bro you didn't have to voice your
insecurities like that that's your
region you're definitely getting
eliminated yeah you're going good you
know you're just really excited about
this side Jeffie let's just say that
looking back at this picture I now know
why I got bullied Oh bro bye why this is
dating you're not supposed to make mom
feel bad about your story by Tommy
that's not the most photogenic photo
you've seen
it's like a mullet like a bad mullet you
only means you're also getting
eliminated to try to get some less out
of this but I feel like I needed to
include that to give you like a full
spectrum of Sean's growth every time
did he just refer to himself in the
third person yes I need to give you a
full idea of Cheyenne's growth hopefully
yeah I used to have a sergeant in the
military who refer to himself as a
source his name was Sergeant Blakely yes
when he would get pissed at us during
training we like sergeant Blakely is not
pleased and someone would mutter you
know we get you that footage right it's
okay when you bleep the word up they
won't know what it is you guys can use
your imagination you maggots let's go
[Laughter]
James James yeah saij pretty pissed
because now my middle school pictures
out there and for nothing that's people
who are just mad about dating and the
rejection life Andy shows up I get it
but bro you need to deal with that anger
it's gonna set you back because you're
putting extra barriers between yourself
and other people and after that you just
blaming the dating game where it's
really you you got in there it's all
about how weird your face was yeah the
last thing you want to do when you're
introducing something to a girl is to
start off on a negative note and be
self-deprecating not in a funny way but
just in a sad way Todd that's what was
funny yeah well these guys are all young
they all look to me like they're under
the age of 23 at most so they don't know
better and I get it yep pretty much
everyone I said the two most had the
most confidence came out to LA you know
to pursue filmmaking an acting oh no way
well you know it's crazy hmm
I'm also an actor oh yeah everybody in
their lives an actor yeah or a dancer
one yeah like I'm looking forward to
like breaking that mold as an
asian-american actor you know yeah sure
let me just start off by saying you have
incredible taste you see how he's like
I'm not a whack
kid you got good taste
right you get the conversation going it
flows a little better you like girl you
look at my baby pictures and you made
the right choice okay Devin yeah Devine
so I've learned that you do ceramics you
like health and you were in a band
how do you feel like all of that
encompasses you as a person sometimes I
can feel kind of scary like having so
many different parts of yourself kind of
make you scatterbrained at points and
I'm kind of like a beautiful mess and is
that who's gonna pick let's go to the
other one who's gonna pick you know
who's she's gonna pick audience leave
your comments right now before you get
to see the result is is gonna pick them
on they can't pick the other guy yeah
it's possible
I'd like to see you accomplish in your
life I think with my art I'd like to
just get so good at it yeah the way she
looked like now she's not that
interested before the other dude she was
like during actor too you're kind of but
in her head that's not like things in
common Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing now
she's just I'm just gonna listen to you
but I reach OHS yeah I think this is the
guy I love that dynamic cool well thank
you so much cool thank you yeah yeah I
chase Kris yes I do
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
all that thickness pad Buddha are you
going to put that in what say but you
know just how she was sitting I was like
yo she her royal thickness no I didn't
think so
what I had hopes I didn't and then it
was not an [ __ ] fact you can see it
from the front
I don't think he's attractive from but I
really was drawn to scare achter his
passion what he wanted to do it's quite
vulnerable to show you like pictures of
yourself as a child so there's like an
immediate like entering into
vulnerability with them you guys are
gonna vote in the comments who's the
cutest young person out of the three of
us okay that's not for me that is all I
needed to see I think that's it for
today's video visit it you're not gonna
go back on that
nope I'm just gonna sign up for a sex
offenders list and so leave your
comments below how cringy was that what
did you guys think
[Music]